5 56 into monday morning got an
inconvenience now but a big headache yet
to come so in addition to some one lane
only drives on both the north and
southbound 95 515 during overnight hours
now the nevada department of
transportation has taken a near downtown
access ramp offline for just over a
month we're talking about casino center
for streets on-ramp to the north 95-515
now ndot suggests you just stay on
casino center up to bonanza and go all
the way over to mlk for access to the
north freeway that's scheduled to last
until early november the bigger more
impactful shutdown oh there's going to
be a big one eastern is going to be
completely closed underneath the freeway
that starts friday night it is going to
run for just over a week until sunday
the 10th
big delays and the suggested detours
well stuart
or bonanza and 13th or maryland parkway
good luck to the local businesses in the
area where indot says there will be
access you need to check out the n-dot
website
i515project.com for detailed information
we've got that link along with all of
our driving you crazy stories on our
website 8newsnow.com click traffic then
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put down the phone
something's driving you crazy email me
traffic 8 8newsnow.com